be live took a while to start streaming
there but this is going to be a
relatively quick stream because I have
to start working in 45 minutes
so I thought I'd just do a quick kind of
instructional stream make a Q&A I don't
think I'll play any games unless people
really want to let me open the chat
reconfigure all my windows here
with the settings with the stream like
the webcam settings and mic settings
using the blue Yeti which i think is
offering the best sound quality out of
like all the mics i've used so far hello
to people in the chats hello toilet
noggin chest bus phoenix live excise
sparks good to see everyone if you guys
have questions I'll be answering
questions I thought I would start though
by just looking at the Carlson game
because I haven't seen the game yet and
I'm hiding the notation so I have no
access to like the computer analysis in
in me chess so let's quickly go through
and then I'll probably start answering
questions uh today longer stream today
is a shorter stream yesterday was one
hour this is probably gonna be less than
one hour I did not just wake up I woke
up at least an hour ago maybe two hours
ago hard to keep track of time
anyway let's take a look at this game if
I can move the pieces I can't move the
pieces there we go 93 what are you
serious
Carlson played nine a three
you
I said serious and then Siri responded
but Siri you have to be quiet okay
93 93 uh I first saw this several years
ago is probably 2007 2006 which was at
the US Open
thanks for the cheer toilet noggin the
bit leader because it's August first
happy August Shep olive played this like
consistently at the US Open several
years ago I want to see if I can try and
find that tournament let's type in ship
all of night a3
US Open maybe more bits Belgium novice
with 11 bits Thank You Belgium novice
maybe it's this article 2015 really 93
No
I'm getting a bit sidetracked here
maybe 2007
more bits 300 bits things Belgium novice
three
okay so it was probably 2007
okay the bits keep coming I don't know
if I can turn this sound thing off I
appreciate all the generosity but okay
let's take a look at the Carlson game
and then later I will scroll up to
answer any questions
so night a3 g6
yeah.he the knight has some use on in
Korea to come to see to toilet noggin
with a thousand bits oh my gosh
oh thanks guys thanks toilet noggin
okay so d5 so they transposed into some
sort of c3 Sicilian like a Latin with
early night a3 I'm going to use the
opening book with me chess this ever
been reached before this has the spit
this has been played over 50 times on me
chess can people see this where's my
face blocking it well people can see it
okay so how many times is 93 been played
93 93 does not make like the top 15
moves
um but there's still over 2,000 games
keep going
[Music]
you
that's crazy that this has been played
before I
so many times on me chess things full
thing for the sub appreciate that
okay let's
the novelty okay so queen a4 is official
novelty according to the VHS table base
this is such a crazy position though um
King f1 so early this is exactly what
Carlson likes to play just fresh
positions without too much too much
Theory too much preparation from the
opponent
thanks to ami for the sub
I'm trying to evaluate this position
like who's better as both sides have
really unusual developments but I feel
like White has a nice pole this queen is
a target riki one could happen okay so
they trade on c4 it was just gonna
simplify after Queen trade
it was just Oh Carlson keeps Queens on
the board 95 I like that black skiing is
stuck in the center
okay stuff gets traded
with upon on
like the pawn on e5 just completely
blocks out the bishop and the knight has
access to some juicy square like d6 but
I have a feeling this shouldn't be too
much better for white g5 just a pawn sac
you can win a five
yeah this is not this is not better for
light I don't think let's see how
Carlson wins this
each six it's logical
now this is a Carlson tie
position just have a grind en game with
some imbalances and I'll just keep going
here prove the rook the knight is so
well placed on e4 because it can't be
attacked
it controls d2 it prevents F pawn from
moving
but how does white win okay he'd
maneuver is a knight to h4 goes back
trade rooks kind of forest
you
what the game just ended
whoa ninety-two and I take c4 can't
really be stopped
that was really abrupt Wow know where
black went wrong maybe allowing the rook
trade maybe he should play Bishop b6
prevent rook t4 the Bishop d6 it just
seems like after the rooks got traded
the knight comes here these pawns are
weak I'll probably take a look at this
game more in depth later because there
were there a multiple stage of the
stages to this game between the crazy
opening and this grinding endgame but
okay I'll try and answer questions in
the chat uh let me scroll through here
and scroll past the bits
a good way to start August a cool guy
st. Louis is good I got here at two days
ago it feels like I've been here for a
while
mine's when you're in a new place you
just adjust like really quickly and
slowly overcoming jet lag
yeah rook d4 is very strong b3 ended it
was B 3 a blunder
besides b3
when there if he was in time trouble and
maybe he could take take take Bishop e5
and
the night would have to retreat wait
this does not look too bad for her black
is a constant liability
tries to run over than king g6 happens
yes and I'm confused
go for this
b5
you
even have a feeling like that could be
better here with so many white pawns
just stuck on dark squares in team g6
coming
I think I'm gonna cheat and use the
engine but if I had to guess it's may
maybe - point three or something
turn on the engine
it's
equal so he just missed a simple like
you just played b3 wow that's so sad
sometimes that happens after like such a
long strenuous tournament even decently
strong GM's will just make very bad
blenders out if you just take Sun City
c3 its it should be an easy draw
okay well that's a good finish for
Carlson
not finishing on a terrible notes okay
so are there any questions does anyone
want to look at like openings or
uh what do people want scrolling through
hello to a solar artistic from Austria
nice
hello Syrian mmm
knight c6 Bishop takes c3 and I take a
five wait what
86 the
take c3 Bishop takes c3 defends upon an
a5 so that would be
that would be bad for white
endgames nimzo-indian and games england
gambit rosen versus hansen I have a
video on my youtube channel of it's
called Eric vs. Eric or I played Hansen
I think we played like six games but I
only posted one
Grune Feld I know very little about the
Greenfeld we can take a look I can show
everyone the refutation to the England I
think I have a study open yeah let's do
let's name this Q and a
[Music]
what to do
mutation to the England gambit
how do we spell England's with it you
right
my stock fish should be disabled
why is it still on
weights I'm so confused sock fish is
disabled here
there we go that was rude uh yeah let's
take a look see five so this is not a
great opening but it's a decent opening
for blitz because I think there's a trap
here we're after knight c6 Bishop f4 or
let's say Knight of three Queen e7
Bishop f4 the typical England trap is
Queen B for check I have to remember
you get something like this
this take bishop c3 and then Bishop to
b4 with the threat of with a threat of
queen take a1 so white will play
something like Queen d2 to break the pin
Bishop takes c3 Queen takes c3 defending
a1 white would leave c1 undefended and
this is neat so let's see how many
people actually fell into this me chess
opening book
almost 1200 people and there are a few
games reluctant didn't know about Queen
c1 mate how do you get this far by
playing the England and not know to play
Queen c1 some decently high rated plays
but yeah this is a relatively famous
trap because all of whites moves were
like logical and it's sad that Queen c1
has just mates so if you ever run into
this
I think this line is okay to go into
Bishop f4 Queen yeah Queen B for Bishop
d2 I think it's this position where you
should not play Bishop c3 but you should
play Knight c3
so essentially even if you forget
there if you if you're forgetful you can
just play natural moves and remember
nice see three after queen take b2 and
now I think most players will play
actually we can see what most players
play either a bishop before a night
before and both of these moves can be
dealt with if Bishop to b4 pretty sure
Bishop to a rippy one first
when a three and then um I think 95 is a
move and see 95 scores very highly here
and this is actually a time where
stockfish can can give very strong
recommendations so I will enable
stockfish for a little bit and we can
see light has a very pleasant advantage
because after trade on d2
pawns attacked the only way to defend it
I think is Kim D AIDS
and white is in very good shape I'm
realizing stockfish is causing the
computer to lag or at least the stream
to lag so I'm going to keep it off but
this is essentially the main line so if
you remember this as white you'll be in
very good shape right swing 70% after E
4 and then if we go back
I guess it's useful to look at this move
Knight to b4 I'm pretty sure I can
respond with Knight d4
just defend c2 Knight d5 is still in the
air repeat 1 is still in the air and it
can keep going here because c5 is
interesting at rook be one Queen a3
my db5 can now be played because c2 is
an attacked and again white just takes
over initiative a3 nice move
and now black is under serious pressure
as probably a move like knight c6 is met
with Knight d5 just completely crushing
so I don't think I'll go too much
further I just wanted to show like
England gambit it's a dubious opening if
light is prepared so I'll leave this
here if anyone wants to like add on to
this or or clone it and review it I'll
share this link in the chat
speaking of the chat I've been ignoring
everyone but hopefully that was sort of
useful
I know people were asking about end
games but if you can be more specific
like what types of end games I don't
have too much more time to hang around
explain when it is good to exchange open
a position and when you should avoid
exchanges to keep the position closed I
think that's a good question usually
what you want to do is open the position
when your pieces are better and try and
close down the position when your your
pieces are not as good as your
opponent's or you're behind development
I'm trying to think of an example of
that
but
nothing immediately comes to mind
so I'll have to
to keep that in mind and then we'll
we'll try and come back to that later
let's move on here would you show some
ideas regarding Hedgehog system for
black yeah sure let's let's take a new
chapter a hedgehog system
actually you know what I remember that
John Bartholomew went over the Hedgehog
in like a very extensive video and I
think it's just a better practice to
link that video rather than try and
regurgitate what he went over so let me
let me try and find this John
Bartholomew hedgehog but I'll leave the
chapter here and then I will I will
share it in the study chat
um so Hedgehog actually I can start with
like c4 it's a system for black so let's
make a comment here there we go
let's call learn the Hedgehog
Bartholomew
and this is amazing we chest just embeds
a video in this study so if you really
wanted to you could watch the video and
then look at the study as or follow
along and like this isn't amazing I
actually never realized like the the
video is responsive to so so you can
basically follow along and save all the
analysis from the video or save whatever
you want so hopefully that's effective
let's move on let's take a look another
question alabang counter gambit perhaps
a refutation uh sure I know very little
about the Albin counter gambit but maybe
we can figure something else
Alvin counter gambit
so I'll be encountering gambit for those
who don't know is d4 d5 C 45 and it's a
opening that again is very tricky I
think it's a bit more sound than the
England which is just bad if white is
prepared in this case of whites prepared
it should lead to a comfortable position
so let's flip the board goal will first
take a look at the initial trap which
happens after white can take and then
black plays d4 so black is sacking upon
and then the trap happens after a pause
III Bishop b4 Bishop d2
black can play the incredible detail 3
bishop take b4
take f2
- and then and he had things for the
follow and then compotes and nights with
check and after a rift 8g one Bishop g4
check if there's people who haven't seen
this before this is a great a great trap
because again white just plays naturally
the e3 is very natural move to try and
trade off the pawn and then it should
take before is natural and it's
incredible black just wins the Queen and
it's got some completely winning
position so if we go back we should take
a look how to actually respond for
whites let's look at this position with
the reference with opening explore but I
think I think the move I would recommend
is a three but I'm curious how like how
this performs on like master level
Knight of three seems to be the most
popular and highest scoring move Ally
Alex thanks for the follow
so Knight f3 knight c6
than just g3 and usually when I'm
studying like a rare variation I'll I'll
turn on the Masters database because
these are usually the most most
high-quality games jacksie thanks for
the thousand bits appreciate that but
essentially I'll try and like figure out
the highest-scoring lines with a
master's database and then sometimes
switch back to leach s database
- maybe delve deeper into lines so we'll
just stick with the main line here
Knight g7 Bishop g2 night g6 Castle this
is something I've never studied before
I've seen maybe a few games in it but
seems like white is is scoring decently
like winning or drawing the majority the
vast majority of the games I take e5
Knight to e5 and now they're branches
out a little bit
Knight a3 is a peculiar move um you can
find some games here I was enjoy drea
because he's so well prepared in the
opening actually what I'll do I'll just
insert the tray of game so he played b3
Bishop c5
over the nights
i like this double fiend keto setup and
this I think is a type of position you
would like against a gambit player just
something really solid something perhaps
a bit more positional or black wouldn't
necessarily be in their comfort zone and
like crazy
a sacrificial chess queen h5 aggressive
wow night c5 was that his idea with
queen h5 the play Knight c5
ingredients.5 is annoying move because
black usually doesn't want to play g6 -
- Queen h6 so Queen d7 okay on 93 nice
blockade
it was really interesting Queen
maneuvers went from from d1 to h5 to b5
to b6 to trade on g8 but this just seems
like a nice positional game because this
this pawn is blockaded it's isolated
just a long-term weakness and then the
rest of the game as a grind
seems like white just keeps advantage
so sometimes what I like to do with
openings is like find one nice
instructive game which gives some ideas
going into the middle game and hopefully
if if people can do this and maybe find
multiple games like find find a good
handful of games then it can be it can
be useful so anyway um let's try and
move on let's do one more and II have is
asking any advice in the Petrov defense
trying to pick it up for black or for
whites probably for black
if you're looking to pick up the petra
of defense catch out of defense there is
a few lines to know recently I've been
playing a lot of garbage Petrov on me
chess for anyone who's been watching
after night
take five I've been playing all these
tricky lines like night take e4 or even
knight c6 and they're they're great
blitz openings against lower rated
players but they're not the most
reliable lines to play consistently so
if you're looking to play the petrov
there's a few things to know
you should play d6 here if you want to
play solid I take e4 and the two lines
to be prepared for our d4 and Knight c3
now you also want to be prepared for d4
in this position as well as Knight c3
and be prepared for the four Knights
look to play knight c6 here actually
maybe there's another move here Bishop
to b4 which i think is also interesting
if you want to avoid a four nights
unfortunate I don't know too much about
petrov main line if you want really
current games i would suggest taking a
look at Fabiano especially his games
from the candidates because he was
playing the petrov a lot and he was
going into a lot of like these main
lines I think one of the most popular
responses is this Knight c3 line not
that Knight c3 but after Knight a key v
g6 Knight c3 here is probably the most
popular these days where black takes
takes and then it usually gets into some
short positions after Bishop e7 and
usually black castles King side like
castles Queen side and it can be a sharp
game
uh guys you should be nice to toilet
noggin
despite his unusual name also there's a
cos ring gambit I forgot about this
opening night a key 5d6
and then night take s7 I think this is
playable even though it's probably
dubious if fact is well-prepared
this is actually surprisingly this has
been played quite a number of times in
the masters database King dig up seven
white scores well
I guess anyone who wants to play it
against the petrov and wants something
crazy you can look to play the costume
thank you scarf scar cries for the sub
appreciate that
but yeah this is this is interesting
d4 is a strong move because black I
don't think you can take on e4 due to
Queen age 5 and then Queen d5 is coming
to win the night
love kinis 7 though
should be good somehow
okay white sand move in this position I
know why is winning somehow I just
forget how maybe Queenie too
we need to and then f3
Queen h4 there's nine of six
my guess would be Queenie - Queenie two
wins apiece and white is in good shape
okay so yeah I guess if you're playing
the petrov be prepared for this follow
probably the main line you see five
interesting move
yeah I guess no to play c5 and take a
look at these games and hopefully you'll
be okay
okay it's just after ten past pond 99
just joined a low-pass spawn I'm not
taking challenges because I have to go
like in just a minute or two this was a
really quick stream we got through
through four chapters oh people can't
see the chapters zoom out here
now you can see kind of the
the full study kind of I'd have to
reconfigure the layout when I'm doing
stuff like this but you have the
chapters here if anyone wants to review
this you can you can you can click the
link in the chat I'll be the easiest
Ronnie boy just learned something called
the Dutch Leningrad do I know anything
about it I know very little about the
Dutch it's just an opening I haven't
studied so yeah maybe I'll I'll try and
learn it at some point but yeah I just
heard the link to the study what else
can I say I would recommend for people
who want to watch content today if you
want instructive content you can take a
look at the US Open broadcast which is
happening sometime I think later this
evening probably around 7:00 I don't
think that's going on right now unless
it is
no it's not okay so what I'll do is I'm
gonna go ahead and raid the chest
doctors hopefully they're still
streaming they are okay
so I'll end it here and see you guys in
the future